hey guys welcome back to a brand new
view we're back a monster on a world
again and today we're back with another
leak and this is gonna be talking about
some new layered armor possibly coming
in the future possibly the summer
festival as well as a new weapon and a
bunch of other things like new jewels
and stuff like that so with that like
the V if you do enjoy subscribe if
you're new I covered the solo guides of
every monster a monster hunter world as
well as the weekly event quests and
stuff like this like leaks tips and guys
to give everyone up to date and with
that let's get started with today's
video so as always I will have links to
both of these in the description below
if you want to read along with what I'm
looking at I'm going to be taking a look
at the layered armor first and then look
at some of the weapons I do not want to
get copyright strikes by Capcom or
Monster Hunter in general so I'm going
to just leave these out of the video and
just talk about them the first layer of
armor is going to be the deaths densha
armor that but this is going to be
coming from the ark tempered vault
hoseok event which i believe we're going
to beginning in the next couple days
this one was pretty self-explanatory I'm
pretty much I'm pretty sure everybody
knew this is going to be happening just
like the ark tempered Kirin one a lot of
people expect that we're going to be
getting that layered armor and we did so
we're probably going to beginning the
death stench for the arch tempered hawk
next up and we also knew this was going
to be happening was the butterfly armor
that is also going to be part of the
layered armor site as well and then as
well a new layered armor called the
diver then the diver set looks pretty
self-explanatory just got a diver mask
with a bunch of armor that kind of looks
like a diving suit but it looks like
it's made from the carcass of a monster
I'm not entirely sure what monster that
is I am a very new to the Monster Hunter
series so I do not know if that is from
my specific monster of course you could
tell me the comments if you look through
the description and show me through the
photo which one it is I'd love to know
in the comments below but regardless the
Alpha still looks cool and it's also
nice that is a layered outfit and the
fourth layered armor that we're going to
beginning is not actually an armor it's
more of just an accessory and that's
going to be these shadow shades
I guess Capcom wanted to make sure that
if we want to make our characters look a
little bit more badass they would add
these shadow shades into the layered
armor set on top of it also being
another type of armor as well moving on
we have the new weapon and that is going
to be some type of lance and this is the
Italian version according to the leaked
but it's called Lancia Stella can dent a
I'm pretty sure I pronounced that very
wrong but I believe according to the
English translation it does a shooting
star Lance and it does look pretty cool
it looks like it has a flag draped
around the Lance with a type of shield
kind of pirate wheel around as the SHO
buckler in a book from Billy
regardless these stats from it show that
it's going to be a rarity for weapon
with 299 attack zero percent affinity
green sharpness and 120 paralysis damage
that's probably going to be the base
version I'm assuming you can upgrade
that to something a little bit more
higher with maybe a little bit more
attack maybe some affinity possibly blue
sharpness and I would assume more
paralysis damage as well it's also going
to be requiring this new item apparently
according to the translation it's called
the first coupon this is going to
require only a couple of those some
rathalos membrane some heart bone and
some paralysis sacks now I personally
don't use the Lance it's not one of my
preferred weapons so tell me in the
comments below just if any of you are
Lance users if this seems like it's
going to be a decent weapon I know that
the ignition great sword was one of the
more popular ones out that it's been
released it's one of the better ones
tell me if this is in the same scenario
just based off of the stats that I read
and then lastly we also have some new
jewels and one of them is going to be
called heat guard and this cancels heat
damage in the Vulcan now this is a new
place this is I'm assuming this might be
a new area it might be a specific area
this is called the Vulcan this may have
something to do with the summer festival
coming up probably a lot of heat heavily
heated areas probably a lot of fire
something that could cool you down so
you don't overheat or something like
that the next one is called detector and
it displays rare gathering spots
throughout the map so pretty
self-explanatory not a bad gem to have
either this one is called dumb master
this is going to increase dumb pods
efficiency slash success rate this is
pretty situational so I doubt that you
would be using this in your build but
it's still cool to maybe have in a
situation where you might need it and
then there's another one called
exhaustion coding which I think I can't
really tell since I do not speak Italian
or anything like that but I'm just going
to assume that's either going to
decrease the amount of stamina we use or
we're going it's going to decrease the
amount of heat damage we're gonna take
similar to the one we talked about
before where it cancels the heat damage
and the Vulcan but something similar to
that as well and then the last thing we
have is a new type of monster material
and this is for Nagas ghonte and it's
called the nurger ghonte barbels there
isn't any information on what this is or
what that means but if you do a quick
Google search on what a bärbel is it's
somewhere toward the mouth of a fish and
it's kind of like an organ near their
mouth so something like that so maybe
you have to break their form maybe after
breaking Oregon taste horn and there
could be a chance that you get that from
the drop or something like that but
regardless it's going to be a new
monster material I hopefully this will
be used in lots more items soon to come
as always let me know what you guys
think in the comments
full of two New York Auto any new armor
set the new monster material anything
like that and anything that we talked
about throughout this video it looked
into your thoughts what that guy's it's
going to be the end of the video today
hopefully guys did enjoy I look we super
appreciate it if you did subscribe if
you're new I cover the solo guides a
monster hunter world that being the
majority of the harder monsters in the
game like TOS traval huzzah crucial a
day or anarchy can't AZ know all those
guys as well I also do take tips guides
tricks leaks all that type of stuff
about Monster and to keep you guys up to
date on what's going on and what might
possibly be coming into the game of the
future and with that my two most recent
videos will be on screen if you guys
want to check that out but that guys
Hobey rest your day thanks for watching
the video peace out